sri lanka has sharply hiked fuel prices
to a record high causing further pain to
the country's 22 million people in its
worst economic crisis since independence
sri lanka has pretty much run out of
fuel and that's been reported widely but
what we haven't seen so far is the
desperation that a common person is
facing because of the drop in supply how
every single day in the country has
become a battle for so many people a
battle for survival
dw's manira chaudhary and sharik ahmed
spent a day with auto rickshaw driver
dylan simpson in colombo
since the fuel shortage has started in
sri lanka it's very difficult to find
fuel
so i have stayed without fuel for two to
three weeks and it's very hard to run my
day to day life
even if i have to get fuel i have to
stay the whole night to get fuel
there is no petrol in this petrol
station so i have a went and asked from
them they were like no petroleum
[Music]
and because of the fuel to be honest i
didn't get passengers i was like staying
in the queue for the whole week to get
petrol
like if i get petrol today tomorrow
tomorrow i'll run the day and day after
tomorrow i have to stay in the queue
again
because of that reason so i have to
anyway skip one day to stay in the queue
so i have lo i will be losing passengers
for the one whole day but okay
and yeah that's a big loss for me
since the fuel price has gone high
we also had to increase our fare
so when we increase the fare the
passengers they can't they can't also
afford the price
everything in sri lanka has gone high
the prices so like normally like every
day we used to buy bread
to have with the tea in the evening
the price of the bread has been double
now
we don't eat like we used to eat before
i i stop at my friend's place
to have a small chat
so
it's also a auto driver
i have plenty of friends to drive out
over here
they also have shut their heart when
kept at their place because they
couldn't find fuel
right now at my house we are using
kerosene oil to cook custard so very
soon we'll end up kerosene
so very soon we'll also end up doing
boots like him
i've done engineering and it's hard to
find a job
i won't get my degree yet because i have
a pending payment to be done
so i thought i could afford by running
an auto and since this problem has been
come up it's very difficult
for me to pay the course fees
some of my friends like they'll have a
watch out uh during the petrol station
like if they see any petrol station
pumping petrol they'll quickly inform us
we all will get together and go and stay
in the queue to get better
i have come here to pump petrol so my
friend gave me some fuel and that
wouldn't be enough for me to run the
whole day
and i have parked my water there i think
i'll have to wait the whole night to get
fuel so if i'm lucky i'll get the fuel
by tomorrow morning
i never thought that my country will end
up like this right now there is no
future there will be a future in sri
lanka but will take some time
for the country to recover